dozens of boeing triple 7 jets are
grounded this morning after an
engine on a united airlines plane broke
apart
and dropped debris on a denver
neighborhood
passenger video on saturday shows flight
328's right engine on
fire this is a really disturbing picture
the plane landed safely and no one was
hurt boeing says
triple 7 planes using the same type of
engine
should not fly until they are fully
inspected errol barnett reports
on the investigation of that frightening
midair failure
in this passengers unnerving video you
can clearly see the casing of flight
328's number two engine
missing debris falling away and flames
coming from
inside it's just dropping people
pieces of that engine fell across roads
fields
and even at this person's front door in
the denver suburbs
there's the engine right there part of
it i guess miraculously there were no
injuries on the ground
and the hawaii bound flight returned
safely to denver international
the ntsb which is investigating says
after examining the plane and debris
they found two of the planes pratt
whitney engine's fan blades were
fractured
one near its root and a neighboring
blade about halfway through
but it has not yet determined a cause
for the failure
one source tells cbs news there are
several incidents
matching what happened over denver so
the first step will be examining these
engines and their blades
to make sure they're safe for flight
captain lauren einsettler is a
commercial airline pilot
with more than three decades of
experience she says planes are built to
be able to fly on a single engine
if necessary what do you say to people
who
see something like this they're already
nervous about flying
and they think this is an example of why
i won't fly
i would say the opposite if anything
people should see
that these aircraft are built to
withstand so much
and these pilots are highly experienced
and well
trained to handle situations
now we're specifically speaking about
the pratt whitney 4000 series engine
the company says it is working with the
ntsb japan has grounded
any aircraft using that model now united
is the only us
based airline using this engine type and
it says
a small number of passengers can expect
to have their travel plans disrupted
this week
as they remove those engines for service
tony
all right errol thank you very much you
know it's a reminder how complicated the
business was
flying still is yeah but also heartening
to see that even with an engine failure
you're still in the air yeah all the
same i would not want to look out the
window and see that no
it really is it's a time for whoever god
is or whatever god means to you that was
certainly a godlike moment that nobody
was hurt
in the air or below nobody was hurt with
the pictures of the houses with the
wrestlers
it is